hi there Steve Kaufman here again
talking about language learning if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe so
my language learning experience right
now is of course Greek I don't have as
much time to spend on as I would like
but that's what I'm focusing on I do
listen to some material sometimes in
Czech or Ukrainian or Russian but
fundamentally I'm focused on learning
Greek and I'm gonna be sharing with you
my experience in starting from scratch
you know this is not a related language
although I at first said there were very
few words common to words that I knew in
other languages as I get further into
Greek I'm finding more and more words
that I can recognize but it's still not
going to be more than 10% so it's a
challenge and there are some unique
things in the grammar and of course all
new who are most of you vocabulary what
am i doing mostly I'm listening and
reading not surprising to those of you
who follow my podcasts I'm doing a lot
of these stories I think you're aware
that we've got this mini story project
we're up to 30 stories in Greek or 29
and I think we have 34 of them written
in English I find them very clever
little witty anecdotes from life to
different points of view and then some
questions and I'm finding that is
powerful powerful in terms of my agreed
learning when coupled with you know the
functionality that we have a link and
some of these activities the four
activities that come out to randomly so
it's a bit of a game a fight situation
to help sort of zoom in on the words
that you've just come across in a new
lesson anyway it's all working very well
so and by the way I'm going to put in
the description box here a link to my
blog post where I outline the basic
concepts behind these hundred many
stories that we hope to translate into
as many languages as possible and we
will have them freely accessible to
anyone initially where we have languages
those languages are linked
go into our library link the most hoping
to increase the amount of content we
have for other languages so that we
might then add them at these languages
to link we are in some languages
Portuguese in Spanish we have a lot of
volunteers we don't have any volunteers
I think so far maybe we have one in
French Chinese and Japanese seem to be
quite weak so I would welcome any
participants who are native speakers of
those languages I may even do a video in
those languages to encourage people
however so the focus is input as always
no the other day I was at a Greek
restaurant I went there specifically to
see if I could use in some of what I had
learned I went there after my hockey
then I went for a you know light lunch
and so I of course I got a very positive
reaction from the from the waitress but
I found that I was unable to remember
even some of the basic words like there
and here and stuff but that's fine
that's expected it's not like we had I
had a major conversation not just
trotted out a few words got a positive
reaction discovered things that I
thought I could say and I couldn't say
but it's very encouraging because it
then makes me even more motivated to go
back to my listening and reading so
alarm you know during this period I'm on
Twitter all of a sudden they get a tweet
that Benny Lewis has produced a video
where he is talking about the silent
period from what I gather somewhat
tongue-in-cheek you know saying that you
basically I mean his theory is that you
have to speak from day one so I think
it's very interesting that in language
learning we have these very different
points of view and people disagree and I
think it's good that people disagree I
think it's good that we can disagree
about something as positive as language
learning there are so many things that
people disagree about where they
actually get into you know fisticuffs or
warfare or whatever and when I was
learning everyone's keen on anyone who
is involved in arguing about what
it's a better way to learn languages
anybody like that is interested in
learning languages so that's good
there's nothing wrong with that and so
if we look at some of the different
poles here we have the extreme silent
period or somebody in Thailand I think
that Rama school where people weren't
allowed to speak for six months at the
other end you have been eased speak from
day one then you have the the people who
love grammar and and you know there was
one fellow who said you can learn any
language in four hours Farrell I can't
remember his name and so that if you
understand the fundamental concept of
how the language works for a word order
then you'll be able to speak the
language which I don't believe not for a
minute but it's fine whatever people
like to do as I always say its attitude
and time so if you have the good
attitude you put in the time you're
gonna achieve good results however just
in defense of the silent period I Google
by the way silent period and there's a
number of people who are saying that you
know the underlying one of the
underlying principles for the silent
period although crashing I don't think
uses this but some people say well the
child that spends the first two years
just listening or the year
apparently the child listens in the womb
I don't know and then eventually starts
speaking so yeah I mean that I think
that's a bit extreme extreme as someone
pointed out adults actually speak in
other languages adults are not like the
child in that you know regard true
enough but why I prefer not I don't
forbid myself for speaking I'm only too
happy if an opportunity presents itself
to try and trot out whatever I can trot
out let's say in Greek but I'm not gonna
spend a lot of time trying to speak in
Greek at this stage because I haven't
discovered enough of the language to
make that a valuable to me experience it
would have the value of stimulating me
probably motivating me but if I have an
hour to spend I would rather spend that
hour trying to ingest more of
language and and so you know the kinds
of things that I'm doing now I'm
listening to those many stories some of
which I have listened to and read more
than ten times so that many of those
phrases that I have read and listened to
many times and reviewed in our various
activities when I start to speak those
phrases are gonna come out because
they're in there somewhere
and I'm enjoying doing that if I spent
an hour talking to someone in Greek at
this stage we would not cover many words
in other words the language content
would be very limited whereas in the
stories that I'm reading I'm covering a
lot of language content I mean I'm
reading that I'm getting acquiring a lot
of vocabulary as I say well over a
thousand words known and I don't know
three or four thousand I don't remember
words that I have saved that I'm in the
process of learning and I then go for
example to my living language books and
I jump ahead into their different
grammar explanations so that as I come
across different forms of the verb for
example or you know the genitive are the
accusative in my listening and reading
I'm increasingly conscious of what those
forms are I still can't really trot out
or you know repeat the you know the
correct conjugations of all these verbs
but I have a sense of what these are and
so I I encounter them more and more I am
occasionally review these grammar
explanations I go back to listening and
reading and so I'm just gradually
acquiring the language and when I'm at a
point and I don't know when that will be
where I feel that maybe a half-hour
conversation with someone is going to
help me you know I'm gonna do it I mean
I could do it now but there's no there's
no urgency so I guess the point is I
think to have a system where you
absolutely forbid people from speaking
and especially if you're in the country
like Thailand I don't understand that it
may work for some people but if I had a
school in Thailand I wouldn't say don't
speak Thai you're surrounded by Thai
speaking people it's only natural that
you would want to try to learn
to speak or to use whatever you learn
here if I go to I in fact will
deliberately go to a Greek restaurant in
order to trot out a few words of Greek
over lunch but it's not a necessity it's
not a requirement and as to when I
decide to come out and speak it'll be my
choice and it I don't think it really
matters I don't think there should be
pressure to produce right away nor you
know should you be forbidden from from
speaking and just focus on doing the
things that you enjoy doing and I
believe because the issue is not what
can you say in the language after one
week or two weeks or one month that's
almost irrelevant it's a bit of a
tortoise and hare situation here the
question is what will you be able to do
in the language after six months what
will I be able to do when I visit Crete
in October that's what I'm concerned
about not how successfully I can engage
a waitress in a restaurant here in
Vancouver in Greek so there you have it
a bit of a discussion of of the silent
period versus speak from day one versus
you know people who think they like to
try to master the grammar who see the
sort of logic of the language I mean all
of these things are there everyone has
to try to find the learning approach
that they find most enjoyable and
therefore that will keep them on task
and for me that's largely listening and
reading as you've heard me say many many
times thank you for listening and check
out the description of our mini story
project which I'm really really excited
about based on my experience with the
Greek version bye for now
[Music]